Sup fam?
This week on Thug Notes we bringing ALL the
boys to the yard with The Glass Menagerie
by Tennessee Williams. My man.
Our narrator Tom give us the low down that
everything we about to peep on this stage is
a memory of his, and that his daddy skipped
town a long time ago leavin his mama Amanda and his sister
Laura cashed out on the struggle.
So now Tom gotta be da breadwinner.
It's grubbin time in da Wingfield crib where
Amanda like "Laura! you best keep dat a**
TIGHT to make sure da boys will holler!"
Mama buggin that Laura gonna be single forever,
but Laura don't expect any bruthas to show
up wantin to woo her and sh*t, since she got a busted-a**
foot and always actin' all shy and sh*t.
Amanda start runnin her mouth bout how she
was SO fine back in the day that she had 17
bustas in ONE AFTERNOON tryna' get a crack
at dat ghetto booty.
Amanda say she could've bagged a rich playboy
but she chose their scrub-ass daddy instead.
Later, Laura makin' sho her glass collection
shine when mama gets all turnt sayin "Laura!
Why ain't you been goin to dat school I paid
for?"
Apparently, Laura been duckin out and walkin
round bird houses n' s***.
Amanda bout HAD IT when she like: "Girl.
Has there EVER been a brutha you wanted a
piece of?"
"Yeah there was this FLY playa named Jim back
in high school who used to call me blue roses."
But Jim was too happenin' to kick it wit Laura.
Couple months later, Amanda getting all in
Tom's grill when he snap and say "Woman!
Stop riding my nuts tryna control me!
I'm the one bringin home da bread!"
Tom peace out to the movies, but mama say
he prolly doin somethin scandalous.
Brutha call her a witch and bails.
Next morning, Tom apologizes for bein a dick
and say he go to the movies cuz he jonezin
for a life of adventure.
Mama say "boy get yo head outta yo a**.
We gotta make plans for Laura.
Hook her up with one of them warehous boys
you work with."
So later Tom tell mama he got a dude named
O'Connor droppin' by.
Amanda loses her sh*t tryna prep and Tom say
"Chill.
He don't know bout Laura.
I mean, real talk- she crippled and spend
all day with her glass animals."
Next night, Tom start talkin about dat boy
Jim who Laura used to have the hots for.
Dude was BALLIN' man- he had mad hoop skillz,
was the president of erry damn club, and could
even drop some ill rhymes!
Thangs sho done change; cuz now he grindin
away at the same broke-a** job as Tom.
Amanda stuffs Laura's bra so dem tittays look
fine, then she drop the big news: the cat
droppin by is JIM.
Laura wigs out so hard dat when the boys arrive,
Laura chokes and gotta dip out to another
room. Damn Laura.
Jim and Tom chill and conversate bout the
warehouse.
Apparently, Tom bout to get the boot, but
he already got plans to join the Merchant
Seaman's Union.
Matta fact, he signed up using the cheddar
he was s'posed to pay the electric bill with.
Amanda busts in jabberin AGAIN Bout how all
the bruthas wanted her back then.
It's all sippin n' chowin til BAM- da lights
go out.
They spark some candles and Amanda tells Jim
to pour up a glass of wine for Laura.
Jim start throwin game at Laura, callin her
an old fashioned type of girl and sayin he
never noticed her janky leg back in high school.
Laura talkin bout school and her glass collection
when Jim say "girl- you so fly and you don't
even know it.
You just need some confidence boo!"
Then Laura show him her favorite thang- a
glass unicorn.
Jim hear somebody drop some fresh beats nearby
so he ask Laura to dance.
They bringin it on the dance floor when CRASH-
dat Unicorn gets busted.
Brutha thinkin' he gotta build her confidence,
so he kiss her but then immediately recognize
he dun f***ed up- cuz turns out, he's getting
married next month.
Damn.
Laura gives him the broken unicorn as a souvenir.
Gee, thanks.
When Amanda comes in, Jim say "Yo. gotta bounce.
I'm engaged.
Thanks for dinner and the unicorn though."
Amanda just about s***s herself and start
gettin' crunk on Tom: sayin he made em look
like fools bringin hom an engaged man, and
dat he ain't nuthin but a selfish a**hole
whose head always in the clouds.
Tom chunks deuces outta dat trap to get his
adventure on.
But no matta' how far he go, he always thinkin
of his po' sister.
This play is a choice example of what my boy
T-Will call "Plastic theater."
In da PT game, errything on stage- I'm talkin
props, sounds, music, lighting- reppin' the
things goin on inside the chracters domes.
And in The Glass Menagerie, all dat mess showin
how da Wingfield family's dreams ain't jivin
with reality.
See, erry member of this crew got some fantasy
world that they livin' in.
Laura spend her dayz chillin wit her glass
menagerie- creating a place where she ain't
gotta deal with all dem real life hassles-
her mama always doggin her, bein shy, buggin
out at school, I could go on playa.
And Williams, gettin on his plastic theater
jam, describe the reality of Laura's situtation
by comparing her to dat glass.
Just peep this stage direction, B: “A fragile,
unearthly prettiness has come out in Laura:
she is like a piece of translucent glass touched
by light, given a momentary radiance, not
actual, not lasting.”
But dat glass colelction ain't da only thing
reppin Laura.
Laura called "Blue Roses" cuz she IS a blue
rose: she mad sensitive, always feelin' blue
and got a unique kinda beauty that you don't
usually find in the hood.
Dat beezy Amanda always livin in the past-
when she was a sexy southern belle who could
get any brutha with just one twerk.
Now she a single mom who got burned by some
lil b**** and is now livin a bleak-a** life.
Dat disparity between life in her mind and
life on the real makin her act a damn fool:
like when her wrinkly a** was wearin a dress made
for young hoochies.
Tom dream bout writing and livin' an adventurous
lifestyle since grindin' at the warehouse
is hella weak.
Boy talk smack to his mama, and even boost
cash from the family just to add flavor to
his own game.
Even though he peaced out to live da high
life- surprise surprise - sometimes you dreams
get s*** on by reality.
Boy's future become just as bunk as his past.
“...I was pursued by something...all at
once my sister touches my shoulder.
I turn around and look into her eyes.
Oh, Laura, Laura, I tried to leave you behind
me, but I am more faithful than I intended
to be!”
Jim was top dawg in high school but now he
a low-level scrub bustin his a** at a warehouse.
But even he livin in a world of bulls***-
sayin he takin public speaking courses that
gonna shoot him to the top.
Psh.
Boy please.
The only way these cats can escape the prison
of their real lives is to lie to themselves,
over and over til it sticks.
T-Will slingin' repetition all up in this
text to make dat point.
Amanda always talkin bout some flower called
"jonquils" to bring her back to the good ol
days of perky tittays and rich horndogs hollerin'.
“So lovely, that country in May...literally
flooded with jonquils!
That was the summer I had the craze for jonquils.
Jonquils became anabsolute obsession.
Mother said, “Honey, there's no more room
for jonquils.”
And still I kept on bringing in more jonquils.
Whenever, wherever I saw them, I’d say,
“Stop!
Stop!
I see jonquils!”
I made the young men help me gather the jonquils!
It was a joke, Amanda and her jonquils!
Finally there were no more vases to hold them,
every available space was filled with jonquils."
Tom keep droppin da words "movies" and "move"
to show he itchin to escape.
This type of flow is a special kind of repetition
called polyptoton, when you repeat words that
got the same roots.
“Yes, movies!
Look at them— You know what happens?
People go to the movies instead of moving!
...I’m tired of the movies and I am about
to move!”
It sho do suck a fat one when you recognize
that yo life ain't neva gonna be the fantasy
in you head.
The hard truth is that for the Amandas, Toms,
and Lauras of the world, sometimes there ain't
nothin better you can do than put reality
to the side and escape to Cloud 9.
You thanks for keepin it 100 with me.
Catch yall next time.
Peace!